now I come to this video playing not
expect her again and yeah I play too
much of the CARICOM really let's go for
some Sicilian and yeah let's see if you
place the open no yeah I always played
g6 when I was a regular Sicilian player
d3 okay do you three is early very early
not a bad move but it commits the center
very very early
so just d6 probably going for normal
development 36 Bishop e7 something like
that for some reason is playing even
slower than the meat which really really
happens okay Bishop d7 so at least he
won't give me any double pawns
not that this would have been too awful
but it simply won't happen now hmm yeah
should I just take off let's play a six
a six and B five why not gaining some
space on the queenside
I get really I get the bishops but it's
not that particularly strange mooks
c3a okay once to play the bishop on c1
this just makes sure he doesn't play
Bishop h6 or anything you know Queen d2
probably Bishop g7 wasn't wasn't so
great
but it's not not much of a problem black
seems to be fairly solid him what to go
Bishop to e6 yeah I have very often
played one e5 only for this he very much
looks like a willow person I think you
always want to get to this kind of
structure that you know so I remember
that sometime ago Peter Svidler was
doing a commentary on the ICC on some
some grandmaster tournament and he said
yeah now I'm going to suggest this and
that and it's a the usual I want to make
a groom flood out of this what's quite
funny because he's such a goof out
expert every suggestion sort of not
every but lots of suggestions just led
to grow and fourth type of positions
okay
Knight g4 I wants to go it read f5 I
don't think it's a big deal
should make an actor fear of the rook
rook f8 coming and the bishop on e6
controls d5 so a knight will take the
bishop what the bishop will take the
knight of course yeah the ape on the
only weakness here in my camp let's
let's go at him to prepare g4 even
yeah why this is very very solid it
shouldn't be a problem for him this
position should be okay maybe here but
the queen is covering three points now G
5 D 6 and a 5
yeah it's possible that I always
extended very much possible whoops Wow
okay yeah I didn't think about that at
all but it's it's interesting he will
get many pawns probably this was good
don't want to give him g5 though okay I
want quick quick play here against the
king of Basu and this was very
interesting what he played
we take c5 I take f3 can play no he
cannot play g3
Bishop h3 is possible but not I can just
go him to play rook f2 or take on d3
yeah but you can take all the points so
he's pretty much it's pretty solid I
mean if he gets all the parts
if he gets all the points I know I can
maybe take p3 and even keep keep on the
b-pawn okay I'll take it
check
check
check
check
check
check-check
oh okay can I can go here and cannot
take because of the trip f7 important
check check check
yeah into the b-pawn I can promote yeah
I don't know this this SEC was
interesting that he played not sure if
it was necessary or anything but it was
what's interesting I think actually that
white is pretty good here if I feel like
I'm overextended a bit maybe maybe I'm
too negative but it feels like a bit I
know I have those three points to to
cover and I'm not really threatening so
much maybe just look everyone or some
some symbols I don't know 96 isn't is
interesting I'm I'm still I'm not sure
it's it's it's more like a defensive
sacrifice of course so it cannot really
be better or anything yeah this is no
bad yeah I get B 3 and T but we won't
get before don't get to beef up on mmm
I'm curious I know hard to tell it's not
really necessary to sacrifice but
interesting game thanks for watching